[Music]
and whose track was that David welcome
to Stanford we are so excited to have
you at the view from the top series
thank you thank you for having me I'm
thrilled to be here and I'm thrilled to
have the opportunity spend some time
with you tonight so if it's okay I want
to jump right in absolutely I was doing
some very rigorous research which
started with a Google search on you to
get ready for this interview and what I
typed your name two options came up
which may or may not show up here oh
there we go it looks like we have David
Solomon Goldman and then David Solomon
DJ naturally I clicked the first and
that seemed you know what you might
expect
Wall Street CEO sure and I thought well
you know why don't we why don't you skip
ahead to the second here I thought this
couldn't be the same David Solomon and
then I realized that in fact I had the
right David Solomon but there were two
versions of David Solomon
we have Wall Street CEO and DJ if it's
okay I would love to explore both of
those sides of you today in this
interview if there's a third let me know
look at food so we have an audience of
mostly students I would love to start to
think about where you were as you sat in
the seats that we're all sitting in
thinking about graduation from Hamilton
College considering your next steps in
your career and the extent that you had
a plan or a journey you were going on
I'd love to hear what was going to your
mind sure and you know I just I think
about that you know I think about you
know who I was and and what I thought
about what was important to me when I
was a student at Hamilton College in the
early 1980s and I just say for starters
the world was a very very different
place I see it through the eyes of my
two daughters who are now in their 20s
but their their focus on
what they want to do where they were
gonna go how they were gonna build a
career you know what they were studying
how it was connected with undergraduate
students and now one of them is a
graduate student it was just at a
completely different level of both focus
and maturity than mine was when I was
sitting in the seat at Hamilton College
you know if I'm honest I'm not sure that
I would have come to see the CEO of
Goldman Sachs speak if the CEO of
goldman sachs was ever on the hamilton
college campus which well actually he
might have been Hamilton College has a
great has a great legacy of goldman
sachs partners and so um so who knows
but it was probably unlikely but I was
you know I was I was going through
school I thought I want to go to law
school my-my parents particularly my
mother you know had a view that you had
to have a profession and to her that
were really there was a profession and
then there was a secondary profession if
you weren't going to pursue the first
profession the profession for a nice
Jewish boy who grew up in Westchester
County was he had to go to medical
school and yet to be a doctor that was
the profession when it was clear that I
was going to work through four years of
Hamilton college without taking a
physical science that would probably
exclude medical school is something that
I could seriously consider there was
then an open door to the second
profession which was law school
and you know somehow I kind of went
through Hamilton College as an economics
major history minor thinking that I
would go to law school but somehow I
kind of stumbled into working and
financing I think it really came from
the fact and it's kind of interesting
because I look at myself and I think
about myself in the way you know I'm
wired
I was more of a follower when I was kind
of thinking about this stuff coming out
of school I it was the early 80s Wall
Street really hadn't exploded if you're
if you're a student of Finance in the
history of Finance the 1960s 70s into
the early 80s finance was really nowhere
the stock market went nowhere for a long
period of time the businesses were small
Michie businesses but in the early 80s
the banks were starting to hire people
the concept of an analyst program was
created in the early
right when I was getting out of school
and it was this opportunity to go to
work for what was a very very nice wage
live in New York with your friends and
get a further education and so I applied
to Goldman Sachs didn't get a job well I
do a number of places didn't get a job I
wanted to get a job at the Irving Trust
Company which was a commercial bank I
really had no idea what a commercial
bank did it wasn't necessary in that day
and age to be as sophisticated and
knowledgeable you were really
interviewed at that point in time as to
who you were not what you knew about the
profession you were trying to pursue and
so I wound up with a job at the Irving
Trust Company it was twenty two thousand
five hundred dollars a year which seemed
like a monstrous amount of money coming
out of college it allowed me to live in
New York City with a few of my college
buddies and you know off I went and I'd
say stumbled into it I really had no
idea that I would pursue a career in
finance but it was a job I needed a job
and in those early years you moved to
firms that were giants on Wall Street at
the time from drexel burnham to bear
stearns later there's somewhat of an
irony
yeah exactly see there's a pattern here
where those firms were the place you
went to work if you could really make it
on Wall Street at the time today they
don't exist what do you take from that
when you look back on that experience
both of hopping around but also being at
places that everyone thought would last
the test of time well Wall Street if
you're if you're Stu to the history of
Finance of Wall Street Wall Street is a
giant graveyard of firms that have gone
out of business financial firms are
generally levered entities and you know
history is filled with financial firms
that have gone away I happen to work in
two of them and I mean we have the story
as to how I wound up there it's actually
interesting because they came out of
Hamilton college I didn't have a
business background in the early 1980s
if you were working on Wall Street the
way the malla was set up as you went you
worked for two years as an analyst and
then you were fired and you had to go
back to business school you had to go to
graduate school 98% of the people that
are my generation in finance with the
business school I was applying a
Business School in 1985
and well sure I was gonna go back to
business school because I decided hey
you know this finance thing is kind of
interesting
I'd like to go back to business school
again there's a little bit of a follower
all my friends were applying to business
school and and while I was applying at a
cocktail party I met a headhunter a guy
whose name is Gary Goldstein who had a
firm called the Whitney group still
exists I mean he's still up you know a
headhunter in New York City at a
cocktail party and he talked to me for
20 minutes and he said I have to
introduce you to somebody and he went he
introduced me to somebody at drexel
burnham and at the time mike milken's
jump on business was you know kind of
you know rising to the peak of what it
would become
and because junk bonds dealt with the
credit of companies I had had a credit
training a formal credit training in a
bank there was a group that was part of
the jump on business there that was
hiring liberal arts majors because they
thought they had great communication
skills that had worked at banks and had
credit backgrounds so they could
actually sell and talk about these
securities and I got hired to work at
drexel burnham and the salary they were
offering was basically a salary package
that was ahead of what I would get if I
went to business school and came out and
got an entry-level job outside of you
know after business school so I remember
talking to my dad about it my dad was
like look go give it a try you know it's
it's it's a hot firm at the moment
doesn't mean it'll be a hot firm forever
I remember him saying and he said but if
it doesn't work out after a couple years
you're still young enough you can go
back to school if you want and so I went
off and started working at drexel
burnham it was a really interesting
experience yeah a lot of rope it was
very entrepreneurial it was very open
you know Wall Street in the 1980s was
kind of the entrepreneurial tech
environment if you want to make a
comparison in some ways and it just kind
of worked and I did very very well but
what didn't work is Mike Milken went to
jail and ultimately in in 1990 drexel
burnham went out of business but there
was a lot there was a lot there was a
lot of really good stuff at drexel
burnham but boy I learned a lot of
lessons about what can go wrong you know
in a financial services firm and so
suddenly in 1990 I was out of a job I
hadn't been to business school
and and you know you had to had to forge
ahead but it was it was a very it was it
was a great learning experience it was a
humbling experience but I think I think
net net was a positive experience was a
good decision was there questions in
your family when you didn't go to the
path of Medicine at that time my mom
there were all sorts of questions with
my with my mom you know and you know
unfortunately neither neither my parents
are still around and actually one of the
things that I really you know both of
them died in their 70s and one of the
things that I really regret is you know
they watched me for a good portion of my
career and I wish they were around so
that I could share with them you know
some of what you know what I what I'm
experiencing today but there were a lot
of things with my mom you know my mom my
mom my mom didn't like that I didn't
pursue a profession my mom didn't like
that I married I was Jewish boy you
married a Catholic girl my mom didn't
like the fact that that I want to have a
wedding on Saturday night that started
before the Sun went down I mean there
were a lot of things with my mom that it
didn't it didn't quite John but I think
I think she loved me unconditionally but
um but but you know she she made it
clear you know what what she thought
about the various choices I remember
there my grandmother when I went to a
liberal arts school and studied
government I hadn't yet told her I was
gonna study government and she said
honey tell me what you're gonna study
I'm not going to judge you I won't say
how are you gonna get it you know just
tell me what you're thinking I said well
grandma I think I'm gonna study
government she said how are you gonna
get a job
so there's real family pressures to
follow the path there definitely are
family pressures everybody has family
pressures yeah you've got a you know for
about my my you know my my mom for all
the pressure she put you know she she
definitely there are a bunch of things
about my motivation of my drive that
clearly come from my mom and she you
know she she somehow translated kind of
a spirit of discipline that has helped
me enormous ly you know professionally
and personally you know at times now my
dad gave me a whole bunch of other
things
that that I appreciate especially you
know with respect to really enjoying
life and living life to the fullest but
um but they were they were a great
combination and and you know both had a
profound impact on me shaping me
professionally personally in ways that I
only appreciate now you know that I miss
them and they're gone
looking ahead a few years when you went
into Goldman as a lateral hire so you
didn't go through the ranks obviously it
wasn't clear or at least to me it wasn't
clear what the path forward you felt
would be and where you would go from
there when you join the firm that wasn't
the way to go from what it seemed like
at the time what was going through your
mind and what made that decision work
for you you you you um you know you skip
Bear Stearns which i think is something
that it's worth just touching on for a
minute because Bear Stearns was there
Stearns was a pretty meaningful firm you
know in the 1990s it it did not have the
reputation of um you know firm like
Goldman Sachs but it was a scrappy firm
but it had a good reputation and it was
a true you know meritocracy the person
that produced or impacted you know rose
very quickly in that organization and I
am I thrived there you know after after
um after Drexel after Drexel went out of
business I went with a group of people
for a very very short time to Salomon
Brothers by the way another firm that
doesn't exist and but but it didn't take
there were six of us from Drexel Burnham
and went there as a group because
Salomon Brothers wanted to really
advance in the junk bond business and we
were just all miserable and so within
one year five of the six of us left
two of the six of us to Bear Stearns to
try to bolster its business there and we
started to really really have some
success the business really went away
part of the reason direction went out of
business is in 1990 there was a massive
credit contraction um if you go back and
you look at the market cap of banks the
market cap of Citibank in 1990 was four
billion dollars the market cap of
Citibank in 2000 was 250 million dollars
so a lot happened
1990 and 2000 but a 1990 credit had been
credit had been squeezed the Savings &
Loan industry was going out of business
but by 1991 92 you know all that started
reversing and the junk bond business
kind of took off and you know we built a
pretty big business at Bear Sterns and
by the middle of the 1990s both of us
were on the ten person management
committee at Bear Stearns and so we were
you know we're among the top ten people
running the farm I was you know I was am
I was 33 years old and so I really
thought I was gonna stay at Bear Sterns
forever and I was certainly you know at
a very young age in a position where I
had a big career there but I started as
I understood the business more to
appreciate its limitations and you know
the advantages that existed in other
businesses and I had a number of
opportunities that came my way during
the 1990s summit were super interesting
I was I was recruited a number of times
although I never went by David
Rubenstein who was running Carlyle to go
build a credit business at Carlyle and
certainly if I had done that in the
mid-1990s you know it would have been a
it would have been it would have been a
good economic decision but for some
reason I liked being in a big
organization and so in the late 90s I
started getting recruited you know go go
to Goldman Sachs and it happened because
I met a partner at Goldman Sachs
competing for a deal the deal was to
finance Sheldon Adelson and the building
of the Venetian Hotel in Las Vegas it
was a 1.2 billion dollar financing and I
had done a bunch of work in the 1990s
financing the development of casino
hotels it was actually a good business
because the bank's wouldn't lend money
the casino business in the 1980s had
really been controlled by the mob and it
was finally cleaned up by the government
in the mid 80s and it was starting to
prove proliferate around the country and
so you can pay a lot of money to raise
this goldman sachs that stayed away from
the business but by the late 1990s they
were like you know we should we should
enter this business and so we started
competing for this business and I
noticed that I had been talking to
Sheldon Adelson for 10 years and had a
real relationship with him
Goldman Sachs showed up and they were
just Goldman Sachs and all the sudden
Sheldon Adelson wanted to do business
with Goldman Sachs he wanted he aspired
he was a young entrepreneur who aspired
to be affiliated with Goldman Sachs that
was very you know that was very powerful
I understood it but it was a very you
know a very tangible example of it and
so after that transaction because I
spent a lot of time with this this
gentleman John Michael Reed who was
opposite me John went on to become
co-president at Goldman Sachs John
started recruiting me and I really spent
some time thinking about it and I really
said you know I'm committed to this I
like big organizations I think I do well
in a big organizational structure if
you're gonna be in this industry and
you're going to you know really this is
really what you want to do you know
career-wise you might as well play for
the Yankees and I had to take a step
back you know people viewed it as a step
back but it was a really it turned out
to be a really good decision for me and
none of had I not gotten here if I just
go on and work there for 10 years it
would have been a really good decision
there were a whole variety of reasons
that then I got exposure to things in a
different way when I entered Goldman
Sachs that if I had not chosen to do
that you know what had a very different
experience in hindsight that's easy to
kind of think through at the time I
think people called it shocking when you
decided to leave Bear Stearns but Bear
Stearns were shocked
so Holloway I was shocked I lost in the
in the two months in the two months that
I really wrestled with whether or not to
do it I lost 15 pounds so we all try
that by the way I don't I don't
recommend I don't recommend serious
serious stress as a weight loss strategy
okay you know it actually is quite
effective if you're really really
stressed out you're not eating yeah so
that is the third dimension you say
there's a third side to you we found it
no so you say you go and play for the
Yankees and in the early 2000s it's very
clear you are playing for the Yankees
and then the world changes in 2008-2009
beyond just the kind of financial impact
which we can read about in there will be
books many books have already been
written on can you just describe in
personal terms being in this tailspin
and seeing an industry and essentially
implode as it was happening just from a
solar count yeah I mean so it's a very
it's a was a very interesting time and
it wasn't just the industry was
certainly imploding but the system was
imploding the economic system around the
world was imploding I overtime is is
this became my career I spent a lot of
time you know reading about and studying
you know systemic risk systemic failure
kind of the history of finance going
back 150 200 years you know trying to
really understand you know could you
ever really have a systemic crisis where
the system breaks and and you know I
believe there was a very important
interesting academic exercise but I
actually you know in 2007 if we were
having a discussion I'd say you could
have severe recession but the system had
the right kind of guardrails around it
that the system couldn't actually break
the system broke and by the way it just
wasn't the industry the system broke for
everybody and the consequences of that
were very very severe the narrative is
that the banks broke the system that is
a vast oversimplification of you know
what occurred over a long period of time
whenever there is whenever there's
crisis and financial markets it comes
from buildups over a long period of time
comes from excessive leverage over a
long period of time and you know in this
case the banks had a bunch of exposure
and the banks became a significant part
of it and the banks you know a lot of
mistakes made in the context of the way
the banks were run and how the industry
involved but you know 2008 was the
result of decades of policy toward
increasing homeownership and basically
creating the tools to allow more people
to acquire leverage to own homes in the
United States and then spreading the
risk of that homeownership around to
investors all over the world and
ultimately because people really
believed that the value of homes in a
recession could go down 10 to 20 percent
but it couldn't go down war the amount
of leverage that was putting in
that was too great and ultimately home
prices went down a lot more than that
and the system collapsed and so if you
were in the middle of it I mean it was
it was it was horrifying but it wasn't
horrifying because you were at a bank it
was horrifying because you're in the
middle of understanding how the
financial system works and how it
affects everybody and you know there
wasn't a lot that you could do to
control it it really needed intervention
it needed systemic intervention from
governments all over the world and
that's what happened there's a
consequence from that that we're still
dealing with the after effect of but um
but it was it was really it was it was a
mess and I you know I remember we
navigated in from a financial
perspective goldman sachs navigated that
better than almost any institution from
a reputational perspective especially
coming out of it
we navigated it poorly and you know
there was a lot to learn and all that
but I I mean I remember I remember in
our firm dealing with our issues when
I'd also remember as a banker I remember
and some of this has been written about
this was written about in barbarians at
the gate being up in g e--'s offices in
the fall of 2008 GE and had 85 billion
dollars of commercial paper outstanding
commercial paper being short-term loans
and there was no way that they could
refinance all that and you know GE you
know at the end of the day needed to be
bailed out it needed to be saved that
need to be recapitalized and I walked
out of that meeting in 2008 and really
realized I got into a car and I made a
call and I said you know G G's in real
trouble
and it was very broad you know across
anyone that had financial leverage and
it was scary but we were lucky there
were leaders who stepped up and made
very very difficult decisions at great
political expense that really had a
profound impact on shoring up showing up
the system and and you know that's so I
feel like in my mind that began at
chapter of immense change across not
just Goldman Sachs but the entire
industry if it's okay I would love to
start to dive into that
kind of that picture starting with the
change in leadership so we all know
there was an official date that you took
office taking over a CEO but could you
walk us through the the moment you were
unofficially told that you were going to
be the person and this was to set the
stage a very it seemed like from the
outside of a two horse race that had a
lot of spectators on either side there
was a lot of anticipation of who was
going to take the helm of goldman sachs
going into the hundred fiftieth year the
firm what was that like the day you
found out it was a weird day that's for
sure we can weekend up we can talk about
a little you know we skipped a decade
obviously which is I asked if we could
though right absolutely we can we can
only have 55 minutes so we could skip
the decade because what are the points
what are the points I want to make that
I'm not confused about you know there
are a lot of reasons why someone gets
the opportunity the privilege to run a
firm like Goldman Sachs one of them is
just dumb luck from a timing perspective
and so you know we skipped a decade but
one of the things that's important to
understand is if Boyd had decided to
retire from after the financial crisis
to 2016 I wouldn't have been the CEO
because of some of the reputational
problems the firm had after the
financial crisis there was a point in
time when it wasn't clear the board
would support support Lloyd through all
that and had the board not chosen to
support him through all that I would not
be the CEO well he got sick and had
lymphoma in 2015 and you know I think
came close to stepping aside at that
point if that had happened and he's
completely healthy now but if that had
happened I would have been the CEO so
one of the reasons I had the opportunity
to be the CEO is because when Lloyd was
ready or the board was ready to
transition I happen to be one of the
people who was left and around who could
compete for it at that moment in time
and I think that's an important thing
and so I always I never expected to be
the CEO of Goldman Sachs the odds were
always that it would be somebody else
and I would I was so I love my job
running Investment Banking I was
thrilled when I became
Oh chief operating officer but at the
time that I became president Co chief
operating officer I was told that the
other guy was ahead of me he was known
by the board he been the CFO for a
number of years I never expected to be
the CEO of Goldman Sachs so for starters
when it actually happened you know at
that point I knew that I had a better
chance that I thought a year earlier but
it was a little bit of a surprise in a
typical lloyd way it was a it was a it
was a it was a Thursday afternoon and
his his my office was there was a
conference room next to his office and
my office was next to the conference
room and when Lloyd wanted to talk to me
he had attended cedp basically go David
and you could hear out of his office
down the hall into my office or somebody
that was sitting one of the assistants
would say David Lloyd wants to talk to
you and so you know I went waddling down
to his office and I walked into his
office and he said you know I've been
working with the board and I made a
decision
you're gonna be the next person to run
goldman sachs i'm gonna have a
conversation with harvey in the next
week or two and i don't know exactly
what the timing is but it's soon not
long but i just want to let you know you
know you're gonna be the next CEO
goldman sachs and i looked at him I said
okay I appreciate the windup and the
lead-in and how about would you like to
sit down and chat I have something
important to talk to you about that's
the way he was standing there in front
of his desk you know with him you know
kind of sitting at his desk he kind of
he told me this and I kind of said well
you know if you don't mind I just want
to absorb this a little and he said oh
that's that's fine and I said there's
probably gonna be some stuff to talk
about he said oh yeah sure you know we
can talk about it and I kind of a back
to my office and kind of sat down on my
chair and I was kind of like wow wow I
mean wow this actually really happened
and then my next my next reaction was oh
my god did I just catch the bus by the
tailpipe and you know you know I've got
to really absorb this is really
happening I'm not responsible I've gotta
get my mind around this because I wasn't
as emotionally prepared for it as I
probably should have been so I mean it's
it's very open you know kind of account
as to how I felt but it was really was a
little scared to be honest that that
that first moment
you know very quickly after that you
kind of start to get your head around it
and then the excitement starts to build
but it's a humbling moment and I want to
go back to the kind of thoughts that you
felt right afterwards but you touched
for a bit on the role of luck and just
the way things worked out and I feel at
the business school a lot of times we
can get over exact on how we think our
careers are going to go here you share
that progression it's very clear that
there are things you can control and
there's just things aren't gonna be in
your control do you have any advice for
us in the audience as we think about
graduation coming in June for the second
years making the best decision we have
and then for what extent you just say
you know what they hand me dealt and go
for it it's a journey one of the things
that I observe a little bit about this I
wasn't as purposeful in my decision
about where I was going to work and how
I was starting my career or how I was
continuing my career as people are today
I don't I don't think there's anything
wrong with that
but um but it's a journey and you know I
assume most of the students here if
they're graduate students are in their
mid to late 20s
is that a fair assumption you know
ballpark so you're you're in the very
early part of your professional journey
and you know I'm 58 years old
I've got a lot of energy I'm certainly
gonna work for a while but you know if
you're gonna work and by the way if
you're in your 20s today chances are you
gonna work longer because of progress
with respect to health and medicine etc
it might not be a straight line they
might be on and off etc but you could be
working for 50 years it's a long journey
there's not you don't have to have it
all figured out you don't have to make
every decision perfectly you've kind of
got to get on the you know start the
journey and enjoy the ride and not be so
worried you know one of the one of
little anecdotes you know I like to talk
about just to make this example I have
lots of young people to come to me they
want to talk so I had you know and a
young woman come to me who wanted some
advice I known her for a long time she
had been working at the firm for three
years and he comes in and she said you
know
want some advice and try to figure out
you know where I should go next and what
I should do you know next to make sure
my career is progress in the way it
should and I said okay before we do that
you know just tell me a couple of things
how do you like a job oh I love it like
okay well that's that's good you know
what do you like about work is so
incredibly interesting every day I'm
learning there's variety in what I'm
doing I said that's that's really great
you feel like you're you know you're
really you know all the projects you're
going to put on you're learning from
every project absolutely I'm learning
how do you like your boss oh my god
she's amazing what a privilege for me to
work for a woman who's really taking an
interest in me as a young woman in the
business I really feel like I have a
rabbi and I'm being mentored I said
that's that's really that's really
terrific what about the people you're
working with
oh it's an incredible group they become
my best friends were out on the weekends
we're having a great time you know I
could have imagined that I loved
everyone I'm working with and I said
great you want my advice go back to work
what do you mean next why does it have
to be something next just kind of you're
in an incredible place where
everything's working really well just
enjoy it because I guarantee okay it's
not always gonna be that way and you
know the journey is one where you know
there are times where it's it's clicking
and there are times when it's not you
know one of the things you know one of
the things that I used to say is that if
you know if you wake up two-thirds of
the time and you're really happy with
your job you're really lucky and you're
in a really good place but I think there
are a lot of people that if they have a
bad day they start saying okay what am I
going to change and you know that's just
not what the journey is all about you
know get on enjoy the ride they're gonna
be ups and downs a lot of stuff will be
thrown at you but it's it's it's a long
journey and the the the fulfillment and
the success in my mind will come from
the experiences and the journey not from
not from thinking that you've got it all
figured out and so back to the moment of
taking over and kind of taking us
through the next six 12 18 months now
it's clear that goldman sachs is a
different goldman sachs than it was a
generation ago and will be very
different than it was then it will be
five or ten years from now I don't know
if you know this but we were colleagues
a few years ago when I interned at
Goldman Sachs yep I don't know you were
probably busy I was very busy you know
ships crossing in the night yeah exactly
yeah yeah time for fun too but my dad
actually gave me a bell bottom suit that
it was wool and pinstriped for a summer
internship and split in half on the pant
legs the first day of the internship
walking into goldman sachs and i got it
repaired everything was fine but i
remember thinking this suit doesn't
match the time that we're in anymore and
when you took over the firm you've
changed everything from you know open
meetings an open public investor day to
diversity guidelines and principles to a
sustainability practice where you plan
to put to work seven hundred fifty
billion dollars of capital towards
financing investing advisory work
towards climate transition and nine
other themes around financial inclusion
these are really big ideas that we talk
about in class rooms and have speakers
lecture on but you've made a point to
say these changes are are more the must
rather than that should can you talk
about how you see them sure i think it's
important to note though there's no
question that that that as i lee goldman
sachs i'm evolving it you know i I I
read the press and the story line around
the first year and a half of my tenure
and you know the the press would make it
seem like I'm turning the place upside
down
and I'm really not
but like any organization the reason
goldman sachs has been around for 150
years is because it always involves it
always changes it always figures out
what it needs to be to be relevant and
successful and any organization has to
do that to survive and thrive you know I
think there's a natural arc with any
leader of an organization that when
you're a new leader of an organization
you kind of look at the facts the set of
facts you have you know what you have
and you say okay
based on what I've got what's the right
set of things to do
to move the organization forward and
have the best relative performance that
you can when you're later in your tenure
you get much more defensive and
protecting of your legacy and so it's
not surprising lloyd ran the firm for
over 12 years that he wasn't looking for
a significant change you know in the
last four or five years and so you know
I'm looking for more change because it's
my job it's my job to evolve it the big
thing I'm trying to evolve with goldman
sachs is that the things we talked about
in the financial crisis changed the
world if you go back 20 years in the
united states there were six or seven
big banks that had global aspirations
and there were five investment banks in
the United States that had global
aspirations Goldman Sachs was the
largest of those five investment banks
investment banks dealing with
institutional clients early governments
and institutions corporations and
institutions the the financial crisis
kind of changed everything well two
things changed in the last 20 years
first was the unwinding of
glass-steagall which allowed the banks
that serve consumer customers to get
into Investment Banking businesses going
back to the depression in the 1920s or
in the early 30s when glass-steagall was
created those things were separated and
the second thing that happened is coming
out of the crisis investment banks went
away and everybody became a bank so some
investment banks literally went away but
the Romanian investment banks Goldman
Sachs and Morgan Stanley became Bank so
now instead of six or seven banks and
five investment banks there are six big
banks that have global ambitions and
goldman sachs is the smallest of those
six banks and it's business mix which is
still heavily investment banking
business that business is a really
really good business but it's not
growing and so if you're running a
public company you have to grow and so
the biggest thing I'm trying to do is
I'm trying to get Goldman Sachs growing
again that's the number one priority and
I have us entering and expanding a
number of businesses to get us growing
but the second thing I'm trying to do is
you know I think part of this
secret sauce of our organization is the
quality of the people that were able to
attract to the organization and I think
to ensure that or protect that for
another generation or another couple of
decades the firm has to be different
than it's been it was very closed it was
very private it was very secretive
it was very steadfast in its ways it
wasn't open and I've been trying very
hard to make it a much more modern
organization that I think can continue
to be a magnet for talent in a different
you know in a different world and so yes
I'm you know I'm I'm trying to do things
that I think matter but I'm also trying
to make the organization you know more
open and accessible because I think it
would make Goldman Sachs better now in
the context of that and we you know we
talked a little bit you know earlier
when we were talking about purpose and
business when you talk about something
like sustainability one of the things
I've come to appreciate is I'm running
this organization where we can do things
that really have an impact not just on
the organization but on the community
more broadly and it's important I think
for us so really be focused on things
that we think are necessary where we can
make a difference and you know I think
we're in a position where when you think
about sustainability is a broad topic
whether it's the environment whether
it's you know affordable and accessible
healthcare whether it's you know more
inclusive Economic Opportunity you know
broadly these are things that Goldman
Sachs is in a position to help advance
and I think it's important that we try
to use our resources to do it and so I'm
trying to make sure we're very
thoughtful and purpose driven and using
our resources our assets which are
really our people our capital or
technology you know to drive
not just at serving our clients and
ultimately driving performance in our
business but ultimately having an impact
on society more broadly I think that
matters and I think we do that right it
will help our relative performance I
think it's good for business there is a
business case for there's a strong
business case for it
so we're gonna go to questions in a few
minutes I want to ask just in these last
couple minutes about you we we touched a
lot on the one version of David Solomon
we haven't gotten so much of DJ saw DJ D
saw you know a few years ago I was
working on a book project around
people's outside passions at work and I
actually I really had heard you were at
DJ I really wanted to hear your story
and at the time the powers that be you
know kind of create us in space and
there was a plight kind of this isn't
something we want to kind of open up to
talk about now that's something you lead
with you bring that identity this
passion as part of who you are to work
or at least to who you are each day well
everybody else brings it I you know I
show up at work ready to work with my
goldman-sachs suit on right it's it's a
it's it's it's interesting how it is now
a public part of me right it goes
wherever I go and I love to know how
that feels and and there's so much
supportive there's people saying oh
that's great you're able to do this and
it just seems like that's who you are
genuinely from what I can tell that's a
part of you but what's what's changed
and why now can you can you bring that
to the surface well the first the first
thing I mean the first thing I need to
just talk about a little bit is just two
minutes on how I became a DJ because
it's it's you know I'm a DJ for 40 years
I've always loved music
I've always been hugely into music but
but I became a DJ it goes back a little
bit to the law of the Las Vegas story
because I was involved in financing a
bunch of these buildings I was having a
conversation you know in Las Vegas in
2008 about the changing economic model
of a bunch of these buildings clubs were
becoming a huge economic engine you know
gambling was diminishing restaurants and
clubs were becoming a huge economic
engine and the amount of money that was
being made in these clubs was
astronomical and I didn't really
understand the economic model and so I
went down into a club that was called
tryst at the wind and was shown around
it's now called intrigue for those of
you go to Las Vegas now it it I went
down to kind of understand the model
this was the beginning of bottle service
you know house music and club music
electronic dance music were really
exploding and DJs we're starting to get
paid a lot of money and I went down to
see the business model but I love the
music and I started finding myself
listening to house music and listening
to electronic dance music which was a
genre of music I knew nothing about and
in 2010 I asked I asked a guy named
Scott Greenstein who is the president of
Sirius XM I said I want to learn about
house music we're all about our
electronic dance music how can I learn
about it and he introduced me to a guy
named Paul Oakenfold who will be known
to many of you Paul Oakenfold is is you
know a long long time deejay who really
is kind of the godfather of you know
this genre of music going back to the
late 80s and Visa in London in in the
West Village in the East Village in New
York and he's in his 50s and he lives in
Los Angeles and I went out and I drink
with him in 2010 and we hit it off
talking about music talking about life
talking about business we hit it off and
Paul said to me I should teach you how
to DJ I said well that would be cool and
I said how do I do that and he said he
wrote down you go by these things and
you know I'll send you some music and
I'll start teaching how to DJ and so I
started playing around with it put it on
my dining room table and and started
playing around with it and you know on
the weekends just for fun and he would
send me music and after a year or two I
was like I want to learn more introduce
me to somebody in New York and he
introduced me to a DJ a guy named Todd
Wilkinson who goes by liquid Todd if any
of you listen to be 51 BPM you know
liquid Todd because he's a regular on
BPM and he started coming to my
apartment on Sundays and teaching me how
to mix music I played the saxophone in
elementary school and through high
school so I could read music I
understood music theory understood basic
key theory and so you know he started
teaching me and this one on on Sunday
afternoons not all Sunday afternoons but
on Sunday afternoons for a number of
years and about five six years ago Paul
was coming to New York to play at
Marquee and he called me he said hey I
hear you getting pretty good you know
you want to do an hour at Marquee and
I'd never DJed anymore but my dining
room and and I said well I can't do that
he said yes you can pick 10 tracks
you'll mix them together and he said
don't worry about it it'll be from 11:00
to 12:00 when the club opens there won't
be anyone there anyway
and so I went I did it and he was right
at 11 o'clock my kids were there but
does it really anybody else there and
but by 12 o'clock it was quite full and
I was hooked and me my adrenaline I mean
I had a rush you know from doing it and
so I started doing it you know my
friends knew but on Saturday nights you
know I'd go to places you know in the
East Village where they'd let me play
you know they'd pay me I just like can I
play for a couple hours and they'd let
me play and I played and it was a hobby
and I kept working on it and got better
at it but I really you know except
privately nobody knew shortly after I
became president of the firm which
happens to most DJ's I was I was playing
and I was playing it up place in New
York City and a reporter from the New
York Times you know saw it and we're
okay Kelly you probably googled it up
there Katie wrote about it and you know
so what was then out and I you know I
was describing earlier we were talking
earlier to a small group here my first
reaction when I heard it was gonna be
the paper I was horrified I was like
what's everybody to think how is this
going to affect you know affect me but
then Lloyd Lloyd did something you know
very very nice he tweeted you know the
same day he tweeted out sometimes David
really needs to let down his hair and by
the way is very very hard for me and it
was a way it was a way of him saying you
know it's okay that he's doing this it's
okay and you know that led me to really
thinking about it and saying okay I
really like this this is really fun
I'm enjoying this I'm gonna keep doing
it but I then said if I'm gonna keep
doing it I got a really I got to get
better and if you want to get better
you've got to produce music so I started
taking lessons around producing and and
I started producing and and as it's just
evolved it's become a thing I
I had no expectation you know Jennifer
was talking earlier I had no expectation
that this was gonna be anything other
than a hobby and it is just to be clear
a hobby but now it's a hobby we're
actually you know I have a platform
where I'm getting paid and I'm giving
her way to charity I'm doing something
good with it and that's really terrific
but there's been a whole bunch of stuff
that's come out of it and this is really
what gets to what you're talking about
that I just never expected the first is
it's changed the way I'm perceived at
Goldman Sachs
in a positive way and the simplest
example that I can give is I was running
Investment Banking for ten years at
Goldman Sachs I've been on the
management committee at Goldman Sachs
for 15 years I walked around that
building and Goldman Sachs a very young
organization 60% of the people work at
Goldman Sachs are 30 years old or less
74% of the people work of Goldman Sachs
are millennial or Gen Z so 37 years old
or younger I would walk around that
building nobody would talk to me I'd be
in the elevator and I would walk into
the elevator with a bunch of young
people I say hey how's it going and
they'd be like fine no looking at their
shoes I don't think I'm that scary and
intimidating but I walk around that
building now everybody stops me wants to
talk to me I'm in the lobby getting
coffee people want to talk to me and
they they usually start and that they
want to talk about music and then two
minutes later we're talking about
business so we're talking about the firm
but it just it humanized me and I think
a positive way and I think it humanizes
the firm and by the way it's just not
about me it's allowing other people at
the firm to be their authentic selves to
bring their authentic their authentic
selves to work and I just think I think
it's a better way for the organization
to be but I you know this I stumbled it
to this and I'm working as I as as I go
but it's really changing my perception
of what a modern leader needs to be and
you know how we need to be if we want to
lead people in a modern world and by the
way people are different when I when I
started I I was with a group of people
yesterday I talked about this one I
started if someone said jump
I said how high okay I know that if I
say jump today at Goldman Sachs and I'm
talking to an employee and their 30s
they do not say how
they start by saying well let's discuss
you know why you want me to do it why is
why is jumping good for goldman sachs it
why is he jumping good for me and i was
jumping in to advance my career and you
know personally I'm not a jumper I'm a
skipper because he thing really makes me
feel fulfilled relevant and so could we
talk about whether for me to succeed at
Goldman Sachs is it really necessary for
me to jump or can I be successful as a
skipper you know in your organization
yes that's the way the world's really
evolved and I understand that but I mean
it's you know I looked people wore shoes
with laces I wore shoes with laces I
hated shoes with laces it always getting
tied you always tying them you know but
that's what other people you mirrored
yourself after the people you work with
today people are much more their own
self they're they they're an individual
people can express everybody used to
wear suits all the suits look the same
whether men are women they were suits
everybody dressed exactly the same
you walk around goldman sachs and
everybody's dressing the way they want
to dress the way they think is
appropriate for their job their day
their experience one of the things i got
credit for in the last year and a half
was changing the dress code it's it's
it's really create that base by the way
there was more press articles written
when we announced that the dress code
was officially changed then there were
articles written about me becoming the
CEO and the reason I did it is I was
walking around looking at the firm and
everybody in the firm was dressed
casually except for a very small number
of people and I asked for the dress code
this was like the first month I was the
CEO I say can I see the dress code
because I knew one existed I got a 35
page document that had been put together
you know years ago and I looked at it
none of it fit what the firm was and so
we wrote a one-page memo one page one
paragraph memo two sentences that
basically said dress in a way that's
appropriate for your day for your
clients for your work for your
experience we all know what's
appropriate we all know it's not
appropriate in a workplace
be appropriate and I just codified
something that society had changed over
a long period of time and the firm of
naturally evolved too but
fact that we hadn't said that if you
were a young person coming from Stanford
and starting your first day at Goldman
Sachs you would be super worried about
what you needed to wear and there was no
reason for you to be worried about that
because the world of the organization
had progressed and so it was important
to basically cuff I that and say you
know this is the way we dress a cold in
sex this is what matters and that got
thousands of newspaper articles and it's
really a little bit more visibility than
we need well I appreciate the candor I
really do I think as much as we joke
about the different versions of you I
think you have shared you know the DNA
that that you bring to the office to
DJing so I appreciate that and I think
we have time very quickly for a couple
questions that we have from the audience
I'm chenyu MBA one so my question is
that on Coleman is a global bank and
obviously you guys are involved in many
emerging markets and some of the
emerging markets have governance problem
on like for Gomes case is he Malaysia so
I was wondering what's your take on you
know Gomes emerging market strategy with
you know like sufficient governance he
Minds going forwards sure so so as many
of you know you know we're involved in a
in a situation and Malaysia that's been
very reputationally damaging to the firm
that we're trying to work through and
we're trying to resolve we did a bunch
of financing for the Malaysian
government I back in 2012 2013 and after
the financing was done the prime
minister at the time Prime Minister
Najib along with a gentleman named Joe
Lowe stole a significant amount of the
money that we had raised and other money
that was in the their version of a
sovereign wealth fund and to people who
worked at Goldman Sachs you know after
the fact got involved and the movement
of that money the laundering of that
money around the world and committed you
know over criminal actions and so you
know when you run an organization with
forty thousand people unfortunately you
know sometimes people do bad things but
we own that and that's our
responsibility I mean so there obviously
consequences for the firm because of
that
I think your point one of the things
that you have to step back and you have
to recognize is that when you do
business in these emerging economies a
bunch of the things that we take for
granted in places like the United States
don't exist and I think our view on this
has evolved a little bit over time you
know I think 10 years ago we really
thought you know our job was to make
capital accessible anywhere in the world
as long as it was it was done in a way
where you were providing capital and
access to capital that would obviously
better economic participation you know
the world has long forgotten and in 2009
2010 2011 President Obama was playing
golf with Prime Minister Najib President
Obama was visiting Malaysia President
Obama was talking about how it was
important that we did business with
Malaysia and supported Malaysia that's
all now you know history in these
emerging markets you know the standards
around rule of law corruption
you know we're different and so our bar
in doing business in these places has to
be higher and they think our experience
in Malaysia's raise the bar that doesn't
mean that we won't do business with
governments in these emerging economies
but the bar to do business and the
filter to do it is going to be is going
to be higher it has to be now because
the reputational damage when something
goes wrong is is its it's not worth and
so so I think it's I think it's changed
our lens now we still do business in all
these places but I think we we limit it
to some degree and I think the the last
decade okay time for one more question
hey David my name is Mark Bush I'm a
first year student here at the GSB
you're known for spreading a lot of
initiatives targeted at improving it you
have a banking experience at yes you
talk a little bit about what's in the
action area Jenna to keep attracting top
talent so so I talked a little bit about
this I you know the secret sauce of
Goldman Sachs is is is the people and I
you know one things I'm incredibly proud
of and I see it every day I see it every
day through the experience I get working
with
people Goldman Sachs and I see it every
day as I travel around and meet with our
clients you know all over the world to
talk about the quality of our people we
have extraordinary people in our
organization it is an extraordinary
organization from a talent perspective
and we have to keep that that is a lot
more complicated in 2020 than it was you
know twenty or thirty years ago and so
it requires you know one creating an
environment that people want to work in
and want to be a part of it requires
enormous investment you know in people
and training and development you know of
people
it requires having an organization where
people can move around and have
different experiences so there's strong
incentives when you want to have other
experiences in your career to stay in
the organization rather to look outside
the organization I and you know it
requires you know having an organization
where the rewards with the psychic
rewards but also the economic rewards
and the wealth creation rewards you know
we're super competitive and so we focus
on all that you know all the time there
isn't a specific thing that that I could
say to you this is the next thing we're
gonna do that adds to this but you know
what you talked about in terms of junior
bankers it's it gives you a sense of my
mindset and and you know how I think
about things when things have to evolve
sometimes you have to take a risk to
change them you have to do something
that the initial response to the initial
reaction is gonna be well that's crazy
we can't do that and that what you're
talking about with junior bankers is a
great example of that just a you know
tell the group when I got out of school
and and I started to work you know as a
young person in the business work was
defined by the fact that you worked very
very hard but the minute you walked out
of the office until you walked back into
the office
you really were free and unreachable yes
somebody could call you on your home
phone but you didn't have to answer it
you could let the answering machine pick
up even if you were home you could
screen your calls on the answering
machine there's some of the audience
that remember answering machines and so
you might have worked very very hard but
if you walked out the out of the office
you know at 10 o'clock at night you know
you knew until you walk back
in the next day and maybe you didn't
walk back in the next day until nine or
ten o'clock in the morning you're
unreachable and the world moved at a
different pace life changed and
everybody expects 24/7 you know response
time and if you're coming out of school
and you're a young person and you're
going to work and you're working in
environment where everybody's texting
and e-mailing and everybody expects you
to be connected you have no experience
you have no guardrails you know of no
parameters for how you're supposed to
manage that it takes an exceptionally
confident young person to realize that
you actually aren't expected to work all
the time you're expected to have
boundaries and so we came up with the
idea of creating boundaries and we said
what's a reasonable amount of time that
someone should work when you're young
and you're starting out in the business
and we came up with you know 70 hours
you know it was a pretty full week and I
know that sounds I know that sounds like
it sounds like a lot but if you if you
think about that you're young you come
in you work from 9:00 to 9:00 that's 12
hours and you know you probably put in
you know five hours you know five hours
a day on the weekend or ten hours you
know one day on the weekend does it all
have to be in the office but in the
competitive world that actually is you
know the way people people work and we
thought about that we said okay that
feels like a lot is that sustainable and
we said you know what that's probably
not as sustainable as we'd like it to be
let's target 65 and we thought about
that we said we think we can make that
work in some way shape or form but we're
gonna track it and so we started
tracking how much every young person was
working we could track it because we
knew when they walked in the building we
knew when they left the building and we
started tracking it we started keeping
track of this and this was this was done
an investment banking you know where the
hours of the hardest well what we found
out is despite what everybody said okay
the average person was actually working
less than 65 house okay the average
person was working about 59 or 60 hours
over the course of a week there were
definitely outliers definitely outliers
but the curve if you want to look at the
bell curve
it was very wide okay in terms of very
few people working less than 55 or 60
hours but there were very few people
working more than 65 or 70 hours and so
we basically said let's try to moderate
this let's create a rule that work is
done Sunday morning from 9 o'clock in
the morning till Friday night at 9
o'clock and we'll give you some
guidelines as to how much we think you
should work but we're gonna close the
office from 9 o'clock on Friday to 9
o'clock on Sunday except by exception
because of course there gonna be some
things that will create exception and
you've got to get exception from a
partner of the firm to be asked to work
during that period of time and people
said we were crazy and I said well let's
try it for six months so let's see what
happens and we tried it you know what it
generally worked we basically got to the
point that between every weekend there
were kind of 5 to 7-percent exceptions
but generally speaking people knew they
could plan and we started tracking and
we found that people were working 60 to
65 hours a week and we got to a place
where people felt a lot better about it
but it was it was a bold thing to try
because it was kind of upsetting the
applecart and and it's it's a great
example of when something's not working
right or the societal change has changed
the way things work try something
different and recognize you might fail
it might not work but you'll learn
something then you try something again
and so when we think about you know
talent in the organization we think a
lot about you know how to how to find
ways to make the place you know really
really exceptional and we'll continue to
think about that so to wrap up we have a
tradition called the lightning round
where we ask a series of quick questions
usually they warrant maybe a one-word
answer I thought it'd be fun to maybe
twist the game a little bit to play
towards your music interests all right
okay perfect
so I was going to name or I will name a
situation where you would probably turn
music on force so something like going
to the gym and I want to kind of go
inside your soundtrack of what is the
first song that comes to mind as I name
a situation is that so good
sure I don't know if I'll be able to
play exactly by your rules but I'll try
I just made up the rules you can change
him if you want so
okay so heading into the shower right
when you wake up you're getting ready
for work in the morning what comes on
any commercial music in there okay music
fact CNBC's even played some of my music
so so you're going in you're in the
workplace you're about to have a well
know you've made it to work did you
listen any music on the way to work is
there a Sun comes up no okay no I mean
if I'm on the way to work I'm on the way
to work I'm generally you know I get up
at 6 o'clock in the morning and I work
out I turn on CNBC I work out and
usually I you know I'm heading you know
out the door you know with 7:15 7:30 in
the morning but I really haven't you
know outside of when I wake up at 6
o'clock looking at my phone and making
sure I don't have a text message for my
kids overnight that's something terrible
is going on you know I I don't look at
my phone and so I'm done working out and
I'm on my way to the office in general
when I get into the car I'd like to put
some music on but instead I'm kind of
looking at my phone and making sure that
before I get into my first meeting at 8
o'clock
anything that has to be dealt with music
in the car in the car ok all right now
we're at the office any music you play
as you're gonna go into what you think
will be a difficult conversation in my
head in your head what's the pump of
music well I mean if you know if I'm
playing one of my tracks it could be
feel alive but um but I you know look
there's there I'm not supposed to say
look musics running through my head all
day but it's it's not it's not it's not
like this song associated with this this
with that if you're actually if you
looked at my phone I have 350 playlists
on my phone and
and they're probably about 15,000 tracks
of music if you if you look at the
playlist the playlists are all bunched
by an experienced by a place by a time
by a thing and so you know there's style
you know if you if you if you really
want to get excited you know I've got a
bunch of kind of heavy EDM bangers going
through my head you know you know Tiesto
grapevine you know just when I said that
Tiesto grapevine ran through my head and
so you know it's but it's not it's not
like I associate one song with the
experience it's like what are you what
are you in the mood for you know do you
want a bang if you want to groove you
want to relax you want to go deeper yeah
I mean it's you know what's you know
what's what's what's the moment but I do
one of the things I do do and I know I'm
Way off your ground it's off the game
has no rules what I do do is I'm
constantly sent music now you know every
single day and so when I get a
five-minute break in the office where
I'm kind of like okay what do I do next
if you walk by my office sometimes
you'll find them listening to tracks
that are being sent to me that are new
music that's not released and so you
know I'm constantly during the day you
know during any given day I probably
listen to five to ten new tracks of
music that aren't released that I've
never heard that somebody's trying to
get somebody to pick up and produce so
that brings me to the last question
we're gonna play a song on the way out
of here and it's just a few minutes that
you're releasing on Friday yes new track
how would you describe it in one word
it's a it's a commercial one word okay
fine one senses listen it's a it's a
it's a commercial house dance track its
commercial house dance track it's
something it's it's a genre that you'd
hear on 51 on BPM on Sirius awesome
awesome David Solomon DJ D salt thank
you so much for just
[Applause]
[Music]